[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] just turn around and
you're all ready to go.
Okay,
cool.
Next two minutes we'll start
off
by
the presence of the free speech busters
activism and advocacy on campus.
Know he was thrust into the
spotlight a couple years ago
and since then
she
leaves
the
stage
[inaudible]
thank you very much.
I'm going to get right into it.
I signed those costs.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] so I'm going
to walk through my talk.
I'll see if I can touch on it probably
won't happen cause I usually get
partway through
and I'll start with rule one
which is stand up straight
and your shoulders back.
And I'm actually just start by talking
about a different book in the last couple
of weeks by Walter shy
daily as degree level.
I would really recommend
this book by the way,
Mine,
I can recommend another one.
The reason I bought this book was
because I had this client in my clinical
practice.
He was a fascinating guy.
He's an old guy and he comes to me because
he was thinking you're obsessed with
mathematics,
that you couldn't get it out of his mind.
And he had some other issues as well.
And uh,
you know,
all sorts of interesting things.
He made these little gold pennies out
of the world's most beautiful equation
that needs to happen.
Um,
and he had studied psychology
and he was studying finance.
And I learned,
I think I learned more from him in my
dealings with him in the therapeutic
context that he learned from me.
That's not that rare if
you're clinical psychologist,
you know,
if you're talking to people need to leave
the probability that you're going to
learn something from an unbelievable.
And so I think probably if you're not
learning something from the clients every
time we talk to them,
then you're probably not on the right
track from a therapeutic perspective.
And I kind of alluded to
that in rural rule nine,
which is assumed that the person that
you're listening to know something you
don't,
which is a very good rule.
Anyways,
he introduced me to this thing
I've talked about an awful lot,
which was a principal derived choir
telling economists can feel afraid of
Horatio.
And Creator was the person who
formulated the Credo principle,
which is that it's a very,
it's a very terrible principal,
the principal about tough
cause you have 10 employees,
ten three of them do have
to work with principal.
Fundamentally,
the square root reason will seems to
apply every single domain where there's
creative variability in human endeavor,
but also seems also to apply to
domains outside of human endeavor.
And even even living in general together
can applies to the occupation of cities
and the massive stars for example,
which means it seems to make it a
principle that goes beyond well,
certainly be on the sociological
beyond the biological.
It's grounded deeply into the,
into the physical.
And anyways,
the square root dog goes
something like this.
So the square root of the number of
people in a given domain who half the
productive work.
And so our Repatha Repatha think,
well,
all right,
if you have 10 employees,
then three of them who have,
who works,
that's not that surprising.
You have 10 employees.
One of them is probably
not doing that well.
And now the two are sort of,
you know,
dragging their feet.
Number three might be making enough money
to pay their wages and then you have
three that are
productive enough so that they're
pretty running the entire enterprise.
So three out of 10 that's not too bad.
That's not that much less than 50% but
if it's 10 of them do have the doctor
Bergman thousand days,
30 minutes,
it's 10,000 dead.
It's a heightened,
I mean that's,
so what happens is an
enterprise is competence grows
linearly and in competence
grows exponentially.
Right?
Right.
And this is like,
you just cannot overstate
the seriousness of this.
It's absolutely,
it's all why I think that starting
tower of Babel exists in the end of the,
of chapter one,
that the first part of genesis,
if something gets too big
and will absolutely collapse,
and the reason for that is
that competence grows linearly,
incompetence grows exponentially.
So your member in 2008 everyone said,
too big to fail.
It's like no.
So big it must fail.
And I think this is actually a place
where the right and the left could agree.
If they got the owner
partisan differences,
because of course the right is very,
very suspicious of big
government and the left is very,
government and you might think,
ah,
sorry,
big business and you
might think someone can,
he would stand back and say,
well look,
the common denominator
there seems to be big.
That's very much worth 20 and up.
Now this old guy,
he told me about the credo prints
going if it solve the problem that I
encountered in my research,
I was doing research with Shelly
Carson and Daniel Higgins.
Um,
we started this research at Harvard in
the 90s and we were very interested in
the measure of creative on
creativity and creativity.
Like many what commonly
you lies descriptive terms.
It's very difficult to nail down from a
scientific perspective because to nail
down something from a
scientific perspective,
you really have to put
it in a categorical box,
right?
You can't,
if I use the word creativity,
creativity in normal conversation,
you can pick up what I mean from
the context of the conversation.
But if I make a measure of creativity,
then it has to be very,
very tightly defined.
And it turns out if I'm in
something like creativity,
it's a little more difficult
than you might think.
So,
because one of the things
you could say as well,
people think creatively,
maybe you're a creative thing.
Is that creativity?
Well,
are you ready to take?
no,
that's not enough.
Creativity isn't merely the
ability to think creatively.
You have to produce something
that's novel and useful,
which is,
which is a fairly common definition.
Creative,
creative people produce things
that are novel and useful.
There were quite a few
measures of creative thinking
already established in the
psychometric literature.
One of them is the Torrance
creativity test is pretty widely used.
It's actually a pretty,
pretty good predictor of,
of creative endeavor as it turns out.
So with the Torrance tests,
uh,
you're asked for example,
to write down as many uses as
you can think of for a brick.
And I think it's five minutes.
I don't remember the exact amount of time.
And then your score for
absolute number of responses,
the more the better.
That's a straight fluency measure.
That's called a fluency measure.
And then the other thing that you're
scored on is relative rarity of your
response.
As long as it still fits within the
domain of both novel and useful.
And so that would be creative thinking.
Fluency measures are also visions of
extraversion and trade openness from the
big five perspective.
And so you can tell like if you go,
if I got all four folks,
400 of you here,
if I all had you write down as many words
as you can that begin with the letter
s in 90 seconds and we write orders,
you buy how many words you generated,
you get a rough rank order of your
creativity as well and some estimation of
your verbal intelligence.
But it would be a better
measure of creativity,
at least creative thinking and creative
creative thinkers think laterally.
And so what happens is you're afraid
thinker is you'll have an idea and then it
will give rise to a bunch of other ideas.
So you have loose association networks.
That's another way of thinking about,
you know,
someone who is not creative.
If you've tossed them an idea,
another idea will rapidly spring to mind.
Or if it does,
it'll be an idea that's quite close
semantically to the original idea.
Whereas if you're a creative person,
you'll hit hit hidden idea,
new junk way over here and that will
remind you something way over here and
that'll remind you of
something way over here.
Um,
and a lot of creative
thinking is bad thinking.
You know,
I mean,
it's an important thing to know if you're
a creative person because it's really
hard to monetize creativity,
right?
If it's the,
first of all,
most of your ideas are back there.
You haven't criticized come
even if they're good ideas,
the probability that there's a market
for them is quite low at that time and in
that place.
And like,
what do you know about marketing anyways?
And then you have to
communicate with them.
Like it's really the pathway from creative
idea to profitable creative product
is so long that it's almost never
that the originator of a creative idea
monetize it.
And so that's a very dismal proposition
for people who are creative.
Um,
it's very like creative people
generate all the new ideas.
Right?
But they hardly ever monetized
other people monetize.
No,
it's a real,
it's a hell of a thing.
Can be a creative person
except that it's interesting.
Anyways.
[inaudible]
it's interesting if you'd have an
interesting life if you're a creative for
maybe two.
Interesting.
So,
okay.
So when we have new studied,
so we decided to study
creative achievement.
We put together this questionnaire,
it's called the creative
achievement questionnaire.
And we got,
what we did was we identified
13 dimensions of potential
creative production and
things like a culinary,
architectural,
entrepreneurial,
financial dance,
drama,
Art Literature,
etc. Um,
I think there was an intention category.
Anyways,
we've covered the creative domains pretty,
pretty well.
And then we had experts,
we ran different,
uh,
what would you call it?
Strata of accomplishment.
So zero would be,
I have no training or
recognized talent in this area.
And like 10,
I think it was up 10 point scale would be,
you know,
I won an international prize
for my find work in this area.
And then we gave it to many,
many,
many people.
And look at Iq as a predictor.
Iq is a very good predictor by the way,
Iq predicts almost everything
that involves complex,
complex cognitive operations and Iq is
the most powerful predictor of social
scientists have ever found.
40 anything period by a factor of
the vote for there's one exception,
the correlation between inequality and
male homicide is about 0.9 and that's the
highest correlation we can
do things I've ever seen.
But other than that it's Iq.
And so I came as a good predictor trait.
Openness and the big 5 cents was a
good predictor of creative ability.
But one of the things we found was that
the distribution of creative achievement
was not normal.
You know how a normal distribution works
is most people are at the average and
then a few people were at the tails.
And that applies to Iq
with a place to hike.
It applies to weight and it
applies to the big five traits.
And there's a truism in psychology that
most phenomena are normally distributed.
A truism in statistics auction,
but most most phenomena
are normally distributed.
But creative achievement is not normally
distributed and neither are any of the
phenomena that are associated with
creative production in general,
including the distribution of money.
For example,
you know the one for Sam has tremendous
w the 1% has a disproportionate amount
of wealth and then if you take a 1%
of the 1% they have a disproportionate
amount of the wealth that the 1% has so
that it's something like 85 people have
as much money as blogging
for two and a half billion.
It's something like that and you think,
well that's a terrible indictment of
the capitalist system and no it's not by
the way,
because the problem of inequality,
which is a real problem,
was way more serious and difficult.
Then the problem of capitalism because
any quality is a much more fundamental
phenomenon because it manifests itself
in all sorts of areas that have nothing
to do with sociology or politics or
economics manifest itself all everywhere
now,
and what we found with the creative
achievement questionnaire was everyone's
stacked up at zero.
It's like across the 13 dimension is 70%
70% of people scored zero and
about 10% scored one and with,
with uh,
and you can easily score like 60 people
scored 60 on the creative achievement
test.
So,
but distribution look like this,
everybody's stuck up at zero and there's
a few people out here and they were,
we never did.
And that you see,
you see that the scientific applications,
you see it in hockey goals for
number of compositions written,
like how many of,
how many classical
compositions have you written?
Zero,
right?
And then you have chaos js,
Bach who wrote so many classical
compositions than if you hired a cop,
competent copyist just
to copy what he composed,
it would take them 40
years of eight hour days.
So that's what Jay was talking.
And then castle,
here's a,
here's an example.
So the castle,
you're no potassium.
Well that's for sure.
How many payments?
Zero.
How many paintings did
Picasso Painting say artworks?
How many art first?
Who could counsel produce 65,000 right?
So three a day.
Every day for 65 years.
Right?
And think about this,
just absolutely feel income.
And these were the castle's
right [inaudible] he's
whipping off some sketches.
He's like,
no [inaudible] go online.
You can go online,
you can find me online and
capacity archive and there's
15,000 of his pieces of
art.
Last I checked,
which was a couple of years ago,
it was probably like 20,000 hours.
And it's just staggering.
You know,
you just cannot believe that
someone could possibly do that.
And really that's the way of the world.
And so this old guy,
he told me about the premium
distribution and that blew me away,
get so many bad explained the creative
achievement questionnaire distribution
because we didn't know like what the
hell this is supposed to be normally
distributed.
It's not even,
it doesn't,
it's not normally distributed.
It all.
Everybody stacks up at Xerox,
which is,
which is like a rule to remember is the
proclivity is for everyone to stack up
at zero spree and well,
why?
Well,
zero is easy,
right?
You just don't have anything.
But that's the natural state of
things is we don't have anything.
And so it's not surprising,
just people that have like zero.
What's surprising is
that some people don't.
And then what else is surprising is how
unbelievably hyper productive type of
productive people are.
It's just beyond belief.
I mean,
Nikolai,
yeah,
make light cast off and we get to the
alternating who invented alternating
current that African [inaudible] invented
the electric motor and the electric
generator.
I'm not on any lists,
other inventions.
He said that whole inventions would
pop into his mind in one burst,
right down to the angle of the screws,
the screws that held
the mechanisms together.
And sometimes he would invent things so
quickly that he couldn't get one written
down before another coffee
into his head and the win rate,
the previous one and Mozart as well,
um,
quiet and Mozart was a little more
understandable because he was unbelievably
highly trained by his father
as well as people prodigy.
But he said whole symphonies would talking
to these head at once and it was just
a matter of writing it down,
you know?
And so,
so great achievement is really something,
it's not like we understand it,
but it's rare.
And the people who are really good
at it are prolific beyond belief.
You know?
So when you hear about the
1% coming on the money,
you think,
well that's a side effect
of some pathological system.
It's like,
no,
don't get,
don't get over simplified about
yes it's a big problem now.
Anyways,
so this old guy,
he said,
God,
he explained to me part
of the reason staff,
um,
the freedom distribution emerged
stay with regards to money.
And so it's,
it's complicated and this is why Walter
Chandelle is a book is also extremely
useful.
I mean,
one of the things that seems to happen
is that Iq has nonlinear effects.
So as you can imagine why that might be,
because if you're the first
person to get somewhere then,
except if you're creative,
but if you're the first
person to get somewhere,
then you're more likely to
benefit disproportionately
from getting cause you're
the first person.
And so if you're there,
if you have a high Iq,
then you're faster than everyone else.
And then if you align that also with the
fact that you're going to network with
other high Iq people,
which is exactly what's happening
in Silicon Valley for example,
then that starts to become
exponentially more worthwhile.
And that's the thing too is that this
is also associated with the premium
distribution.
There's another kind of
iron law of economics,
which is very sad law.
They often,
they called the Matthew principal often,
which is an illusion,
oddly enough to a new testament statement.
And the New Testament statement is to
those who have everything more will be
given and from those who have nothing,
everything will be taken.
And that sort of aligned with
another new testament statement,
which is the poor will be with us always.
And for those are,
those are pretty,
those are pretty strange statements for,
for for what purports to
be an ethical document.
But,
but I think what they do is to
point to something that's very,
very deep about the way that wealth
is folk generate that distributed.
And so there's nonlinear advantages
to say having a higher Iq,
there's potentially nonlinear
advantages to having higher rates of
conscientiousness.
There's potentially nonlinear
effects to being creative thinker,
but then once you start being successful,
you might think you start
being successful at,
and then it's a linear trend
upwards or you start failing.
It's a linear trend downwards,
but that doesn't,
it doesn't look like it.
Graphs that with it looks like
as you started being successful,
each success makes the
next success more probable.
So it looks like this
and there's your fail.
Each failure makes the next
family or more probable.
So it looks like this.
So there's,
there's,
there's scaling up on one side rapid if
there's falling off a cliff on the other
side,
equally rapid and so,
and so that's,
that's the magic.
That's discipline and those
things offering together
seem to produce this Prieto
distribution.
And the problem with
the Credo distribution,
as mark pointed out 120 years ago,
he thought it was attributable to
capitalism is the capital say hence to
accumulate in the hands of
fewer and fewer individuals.
Now march was right about that.
Frito had already figured that out.
I think predo predated marks,
although I'm not
absolutely certain of that.
I'm,
I'm hoping that it's true many reasons,
but,
but march wasn't pessimistic
and come on and they left.
Wingers aren't pessimistic enough
theaters because of course what drives
politics on the left is the observation.
So inequality and a potentially
catastrophic if texted
inequality and there are
potentially catastrophic
effects of inequality.
That's the date that's
also well documented.
So if you're a good social scientist,
you should know something
about the credo distribution.
You need to know something about the
fact that creative achievement is a
nonlinear process,
will success.
You should know something about the fact
that Iq predicts lifetime performance
as does conscientiousness,
although not nearly as well.
Um,
and then there's this proclivity for
success to Cascadian for failure to
cascade.
But you should also know that.
And I think this is credible evidence
that as inequality increases,
as it seems to do,
getting Zuora societies
themselves to stabilize.
So I mentioned earlier the
two correlations that I
know of that are very large.
What is Iq predicting life
success and the other ways,
um,
Martha Wilson and Mark Daley.
Yeah.
Have your master university.
These are the first people who discovered
this is shocking research when it's on
it because I'd never seen anything that
was this powerful and in the social
sciences.
So they were interested in
electronic mail on the song,
and I had studied aggression.
Males will make me also more aggressive,
aggressive than females.
And I'll talk about that a little while.
It's not a huge difference by the way.
So if you picked a random woman at Orenda
man of the population and you had to
bet on who is more aggressive
and you've bet on the band,
you'd be right 60% of the time.
So there's a huge amount of overlap
between men and women with regards to
depression.
And this is another thing
you might want to understand.
It's really important to understand this,
this,
the two groups can be very similar
with walking differences at the tails.
So here,
here's an example.
So let's say
the overlap between men and women.
This is substantial with
regards to depression.
But let's say we don't care
about aggression except
when we're talking about the
person who's the most
aggressive out of 100 can.
You can imagine that would be the
case because you don't really care if
someone's aggressive as long as they
don't come into your house with the gun,
right?
They can be pretty damn aggressive,
but when they cross that line into
outright aggressive criminality,
then they'd hit a threshold and that
threshold essentially means incarceration.
So you might say,
well,
what proportion of men are
the most aggressive people?
And then after that it's something like
nine out of 10 it depends on how you
slice it August thing,
but the more aggressive the slice,
the higher the proportion
of men and that's why 910
people in prison are manner.
Even though on average men and women
don't give her that much aggression.
And so it's really important as well.
It should be taught basic statistics,
somewhat sophisticated I would say,
but,
but that kind of statistics needs to be
taught to people that junior high and
high school because otherwise you can't
understand easily the way the world
works.
You can't understand how men and
women can be mostly the same,
but they can still be really different
to the extreme than a lot of activity
occurs at the extremes.
You can say the same thing about men
in engineering and women in nursing.
So the evidence on this is
becoming increasingly clear.
First of all,
um,
the more gender equal the state,
the bigger the difference in
interest between men and women.
Now it's exactly the opposite of what
social scientists assume they talking 25
years ago.
Cause we assume everyone
assumed that whole,
perhaps as you made societies more
gender neutral in their sociological
structures,
that personality differences between them,
the women's would be creased.
That's over happened.
Okay.
Maximize.
And it's because you take all
the environmental variability
out of the equation,
you're left with nothing about
biological variability and maximizers.
And so there's new paper that was just
posted today on exactly this topic
showing them the most general neutral
countries have the biggest differences in
educational choice.
And so it's really interesting and UCR
damn government keeps rattling the cage
votes stem fields and about how the fact
that women are underrepresented in stem
means that there's sociological bias.
All the wives,
by the way in terms of
hiring the freezers,
dispatch deals is in favor of women.
Now the empirical data on
that is absolutely crystal
clear and so whatever is
driving the difference in hiring and
theirs isn't undergraduate rates of
graduation item and it's not proficiency
because if you look at proficiency in
mathematical reasoning
and scientific ability,
mathematical reason in particular
among junior high kids,
women and manner,
there are girls and boys
basically indistinguishable
and if you follow up high
achieving women from junior high who have,
who are disproportionately
intelligent mathematics,
what happens is they don't
go into mathematics or into
the stem fields because
the known interested in it.
It's not because they are
pretty important thing to know,
right?
It differences in ability
that's driving this,
it's difference in interest and the
difference in interests between men and
women are the biggest psychometric
differences that we know of between the
genders,
bigger than personality,
different stuff.
For example,
which are also big enough
to have walloping affects
FFA also going off after you
get the average.
So anyways,
back to this old guy,
he um,
he,
he said to me he'd been thinking a lot
about the previous just reaching in.
His theory was
there are a lot of factors that drive the,
the distribution of wealth because
he was most concerned about well,
but what happens is that as a society
ratchets forward the proclivity for wealth
distributed self on equally nonce and
mounts and mounts and mounts until there's
so many people stacked up at zero that
they flip the board over because zero is
a very difficult place to escape from.
You know,
you can fall into a poverty trap where
you're so poor that nothing you do gets
you going,
it can't get any traction.
You kind of know that if you had just
tried to start a business because the
hardest,
the most difficult customer
to find for your businesses,
the first customer is
disproportionately difficult.
Once you find one,
the second one is way easier.
And once you have a hundred it's like all
of the hundred and first is relatively
simple.
But that first paying customer,
yeah,
good luck with that.
It's virtually impossible.
So his idea was that
the,
Oh and I can tell you other,
some other interesting
things about this too,
he turned me on to the work of a group
of people called economy physicists.
And I talking to what
quantum physicists is,
those people don't exist.
You can go look on,
you can go look online and they have
interesting animations to be a quantum
physicist.
And one of the things they do here,
and here's a way of,
of imagining how wealth
distributes itself.
So imagine that I gave
everybody in the room $10 okay,
so you all have $10 and so you're
at a state of maximum equality,
right?
And now you start to engage in a trading
game and it's a simple trading game.
You,
you,
you just go up to someone
and you flip a coin.
If it's heads,
then you buy a fictitional banana from
them and eat it and you give them adult.
And so you walk away with
nine and they walk away,
let them and you just keep trading.
Okay?
So what happens first is that there
are a stack managing the Grep.
Everyone's stacked up a $10 now he's
starting to trade just as many people when
as lose.
So you get a normal distribution first.
But then after 10 bad trades,
some poor sucker has 10 tales
in row and then they hit zero.
But what happens when you hit zero,
you're own the game,
man,
you're done.
And so then everyone keeps trading.
So what happens?
Well,
that distribution starts to turn it
from a normal distribution of this tail
starts to stack up as people
stack up at zero zero was mom,
and then the number of people who are
winning the get smaller and smaller and
smaller,
the one person has all the mind.
Now you know that because
you've played an awful
right.
That's what happens to monopoly game.
If the game is over when
one person wins everything.
And so you can mark,
this is such a robust phenomenon
that you've been put online,
but you can get along with them.
Monopoly game.
And so we really do understand this now.
The problem is,
or the problem that my old clients,
they bought the problem with regards to
the proclivity of money to distribute
itself in that manner with
reverse feed on a physicist.
So that was one of the
graphs they produced.
They also showed that money tends to
distribute itself and the society and can
be worn by the same equations as gas
distributing itself into a vacuum.
That's another example of how
fundamental a problem this is.
This is a fundamental problem and it
can't be wait hand waved away with some
reference to the vagaries
and political systems.
So,
so that was his,
his hypothesis is that all the game
kept going until two few people won
everything.
And then there'd be a revolution
because the people at the bottom,
especially the angry young males,
because they're very status conscious
and if they can't live themselves off the
bottom rung and they're not interesting
to women and so they're not in the
dating game,
the main game at all.
And that makes them hyper aggressive.
And that's what's driving the correlation
between male homicide and inequality.
Which is about 0.9,
as I said.
So if you go to counties across,
this is between countries and
within countries by the waist.
Absolutely robust data.
And so what you find is if you go
places where everyone's pouring,
the men are quiet.
And if you go places where
everyone's rich but then aren't fine.
But if you both places where there's this
steep gradient between rich and poor,
so neighborhoods that are
mixed economic with that say,
then the male homicide
rates starts to ratchet up.
And you can imagine that it's the most
aggressive males by temperament that get
most aggressive soonest
as inequality gets crazy.
So there's still the
psychological component,
but what's driving it
fundamentally is inequality.
And so the reason we're not,
when I first,
that was Martin Daly
and Marco Wilson's work,
they're both Canadian traffic
McMaster and brilliant,
brilliant,
brilliant work.
Um,
they also demonstrated because
they studied homicides in Chicago,
in the inner cities,
and they concluded that for a typical
inner city dweller in Chicago,
homicide wasn't effective status move
with regards to moving yourself up the
hierarchy because you,
you,
you be in a,
within race competition,
first of all because most murders occurred
within race and so most of that was
dominance dispute and you plea bargain.
And then if it,
if it was our,
it was the sort of fight
to turned into a murder,
this sort of dispute that
turned into a murder.
You could claim self defense,
plea,
bargain it down to manslaughter,
be in jail hypothetically for three years,
but you give them after 18 months and
your street pregnant guys enough so that
it was actually a viable
economic decisions.
It's harsh modeling,
right?
Like real social science produces
results and if no one likes
the findings are real social
scientists and you go home.
No,
that's why I think you've been trust in
gender data on personality by the way,
because you know,
it's a truism that the social sciences
or are left leaning as to say the least.
They're left leaning.
And so the fact that social scientists
have found and gender differences in
personality maximize any
Galitary and societies,
but that's rock solid data.
There's no one was like having a party
when they discovered that no one was
going to,
oh,
that's exactly what we're hoping.
He isn't it good to like no,
it's like no,
that can't be right.
We bet in like quadrupled our
sample size and do 10 more analysis.
Oh,
here it is again.
I guess we have to publish this.
That's the lines of thing.
So,
so another example of that,
I can say this,
there was,
this is also with regards
to the inequality is that,
um,
I spent a lot of time
reading the ICU literature.
I started that about
20 years ago and I was,
I was reading out because while I
was interested in what predicts human
performance across time and
a ton of Iq definitely does.
And I keep it by the way,
they're very easy to design.
So I'll kind you how to make an Iq test.
It's real simple.
So imagine that you have that
Universal Library of questions.
I don't care what type
of questions they are.
Mathematical Puzzles,
verbal puzzles,
general knowledge,
vocabulary,
like any sort of question that
someone could answer and that,
so maybe some people couldn't.
So then they'd have to be questions
with a certain degree of difficulty.
So imagine you have 100,000
questions like that.
You just throw them in a pile and then
you randomly select a hundred of them and
then you give them to 400 people and
you tell me up their scores and you rank
order the scores.
Not Exactly.
You should correct for age,
but forget about that.
Fundamentally.
That's how I view and then can find.
So you took those hundred vendors
questions and you gave him never,
when you rank ordered their,
their,
their performance.
Let's say you pull up another 100 and
you give them to the same 400 people and
you produced another rank order,
right?
And you correlated the two rank orders,
you'd find that the correlation was
about [inaudible] 93 something like that.
So the people who did really well on
the first hundred set of questions are
overwhelmingly likely to be the people
to do very well with the second set of a
hundred questions.
And that's all there is to Iq.
That's the whole damn picture now.
And then that predicts longterm
life success with enough potency.
So imagine you were picking people for
a job and used an Iq test to pick them,
or you chose the randomly.
So if you didn't chose the randomly,
it would be a 50% failure rate if he chose
them with Iq test to be a 25% failure
rate.
And so it's a walloping effect
and everyone knows that really,
you know,
you know perfectly well that
complex cognitive operations
are easier for smart people.
It's like that's just not that
stag when your realization never,
we're not so happy about the corollary,
which is the complex
cognitive operations are very,
very difficult for people.
Learn smart.
We don't like that.
No wonder,
no wonder because it's a terrible thing.
So anyways,
the US military has it been
doing Iq testing since like 19,
I think 19,
19 really,
really early.
And you think,
well why?
Well,
partly because during times of emergency,
like work on
when you have to ramp up or else then
maybe you want to figure out a way to
select people rapidly so you can
figure out who should be officers from,
who should be soldiers critically.
So like you don't lose the war.
It's actually very important.
And so the army,
the armed forces in the US get a lot of
Iq research and established a lot of the
basic segment.
You're coming,
you're standing of Iq Cuban,
um,
about 20 years ago might
be longer than that.
Um,
there was a legal,
there's a new law passed in the United
States with regards to investing in
people into the armed forces.
So imagine first,
there's another example.
Reliable social satire that hit.
So now you run the armed forces.
So what's your problem?
First problem is manpower shortage,
especially if it's wartime.
But even in these times,
it's hard to get enough
people into the military.
So what's your goal?
Take everyone you possibly can.
That's your goal,
right?
And let's say it's splots war type,
that's bloody obvious.
You want to take everyone you can.
But then there's another layer,
which is,
let's say it's peace time and you want
to keep the armed forces functional,
but you also want the armed forces to
play another rule which they couldn't
play,
which would be to take
people from the underpass,
right?
Things stack up at zero and trained them
to do something useful and move them
into the working class or maybe in the
middle cloud because the armed forces for
compared to the u s that the news doesn't
ave with social mobility and logically
so,
okay,
so then you have people
who are doing the research,
who are damn motivated to take.
Everyone may can and also to believe that
training will work because that's what
you'd hope.
If you're going to take every one,
you're going to hope
that training will work.
Obviously one of the
armed forces conclude,
do you have an Iq of less than 83 it's
illegal to induct you into the armed
forces.
I think.
Well,
so what?
Yeah.
So what one in camp,
right?
So you think about that
among the most desperate
employers in the United States,
the conclusion has been that 10% of
the population is without sufficient
cognitive resources to do anything in a
reasonably complex cognitive department
that isn't positively counter productive
pasture fate.
It's a catastrophe because
you know the liberal thing,
well we're all equal.
You can train someone to do anything.
It's like,
no you can't.
That's wrong.
It's known is just wrong.
It's a tongue believe want,
want serious,
serious,
wrong.
And then the conservative say,
well there's a job for everybody and they
just get off your lazy ass and do it.
It's like,
no,
that's no.
I mean if you were are in the lower
quintile and cognitive ability and you're
highly conscientious,
you work hard,
that does increase your
chances of gainful employment.
But there's a lot,
here's the data,
basically people with an Iq of 90
or less and that's more like one,
four,
something like that.
They'd be more,
probably more,
can't read well enough
to follow instructions.
Right.
I think about that cause it was like,
I know what your
definition of literacy is.
Literacy isn't puzzling of words,
right?
You're not literate until you're
not a puzzling out words at all.
You don't even puzzling on phrases,
right?
You've automatized your reading ability
to the point where you look at a word
instantly read him.
But even more so you glance at a phrase
and you're not fingering hook what the
words are.
You're,
you're interacting with
the meaning of the words.
Okay,
let's call that literacy.
Okay.
90 Iq and below.
No.
Okay.
So that's,
and this is something we're point,
I'm dwelling on this book because I'm
obsessed with the idea of inequality and
the unequal district 12 the m Mv unequal,
what we call it,
a distribution of creative ability.
It's an obsession because
it's so important.
But you know,
the thing is just the word producing a
landscape around us cause increased rate
cognitively complex,
right?
Like how well are you going to do with
your damn job if you can't use you or
example,
it's like using a computer
that's not that easy.
You know,
it's not a simple thing.
And if you're not literate,
then good luck to you and
using your damn computer.
I had another client who he
must have had an Iq of about,
I would think somewhere between 70 and 80,
and it was just one of many,
many problems he had.
Um,
and I tried to teach him to fold
up paper and put it in an envelope.
And I guess he had a
job that required down.
And I watched him do that.
Like it's really hard to fold the paper
in three and put it into an envelope
because the envelope is exactly the
same size as the pain with walks.
Right?
It's exactly the same size.
So if you have a cool twice,
and so if you're out by two
millimeters on each fold,
the paper won't fit into the envelope.
And that's,
that's not,
it's the same in terms of,
of the width of the folded paper.
Right.
Do you have to follow exactly in
three for it to fit in the envelope?
And if you have for what you call a
volunteer job where your job is to fold
letters,
put them in envelopes,
you have to do that precisely
and accurately at high speed.
Oh,
he couldn't do it.
I trained him for like 26 hours,
something like that and just
made me sweat like really,
really hard on him.
That was,
I mean he know he had a bit of a tremor.
You yeah.
Other problems as well.
And then it was so funny,
funny.
I mean it was impossible to find them
a job and trying to find someone to
volunteer job.
You think so try to find
someone a real job as hard.
You just try finding,
getting them on a volunteer job,
you have to do a police
screen for example.
And then we have to do
the paperwork for that.
So it was like,
forget that that wasn't happening.
And I sent them off.
This was an Ontario I sent them off to.
There are some government agencies would
be set up under the last conservative
already can help people do,
you know,
we're looking for work and they have
specialists hired and he told him to Oh,
you know,
type up your resume and distributed.
Yeah.
Okay.
That was not helpful.
No Tie,
no resume.
That's a big problem.
And so there are way more people up there
like that that you think way more and
we do not know what to do about that.
And blaming it on capitalism isn't going
to help because it's not the fault of
capitalism,
but also ignoring the fact that inequality
exists and that people tend to stack
up at zero and that there are massive
differences in individual productivity and
people don't reward it
disproportionately ignoring all of that.
That's not gonna help either.
And so,
okay,
so,
so anyway,
so the oldness this old guy in this world,
and I talked to on that,
first of all,
I couldn't believe that I had been trained
as a psychologist for like 25 years,
something like that.
It's only 15 anyways,
plenty long enough.
And I've never heard of
a premium distribution.
And I thought that those things
were normally distributed.
It's an APP.
It's just like a seriously wrong,
I couldn't believe that.
I haven't encountered that somewhere.
It's still the standard speed because
it's such a fundamental phenomenon.
Um,
and his,
his idea was,
well,
you know,
inequality amounts up and then
there's revolution so well,
so then
because if you stack up at zero,
why not flip the board?
You know,
if you're down to your last $10 in your
playing monopoly and you're going to get
shocked when you lose many minds
moreover and starting to games,
there's just no reason to participate
when you're stuck at zero.
Even if there's a high chance of
mortality by playing a new game,
you might as well risk,
especially through mail.
And that is exactly what characterizes
the history of the human race.
So Chanel just book the great leveler
and I've just been working my way through
it and I read a description
and he basically came up
with the same theory that
this whole plan of mine and
come up with that inequality,
mountain disorderly.
And then there's revolutions.
And so Chanelle went through the data
going back well as far back as you can,
15,000 years.
Sometimes even if you go back
into Neolithic burial cemeteries,
you can get an estimate of the dollar
value of the artifacts that are burdened
with people and then you can graph the
dollar value of the artifacts and you can
see what sort of distribution there is
and there's a pretty low distribution
right there.
You guys are like gold,
she think and there's like one of
them in the cemetery and then there's,
you know,
a hundred people who were very good,
absolutely nothing and so you can,
you can track it there.
He tracked it and Quality
Mark Hunter gatherers.
If there's no surplus,
there's no hunch in the pool.
There's still,
I think what would be his health was
inequality of social contacts and there's
any quality of sexual success even when
there's no surplus of material wealth,
so you can't get rid of inequality
even if you get rid of surplus material
wealth.
Once you introduce
surface material wealth,
which you probably want to do because
otherwise everyone's living chem tomorrow.
Then inequality starts
wrapping up in exhort.
And so,
and that's true.
Now if he did it,
a number of very interesting analysis,
one question was,
well,
there are continuous with tends to
ameliorate inequality across the centuries
across the IELTS,
right?
Because it's a fundamental problem.
If you analyze the relationship between
the position of a government on the
ideological spectrum and inequality,
do you find any relationship?
And that answer is no.
It doesn't matter if it's
electric government or raping.
Government has no effect
whatsoever on inequality.
No one knows what to do about.
And so the only thing
that Chanel on health,
we're four things,
and I don't know for rememberable,
he called them the four horsemen.
So you can imagine what they are,
um,
epidemics,
a violent revolution war.
And there's one other equally terrible.
So basically what Chanel farm goes,
but if you flattened everyone,
then you flat note,
I didn't put distribution.
But then if you start mounting up again,
no evidence whatsoever that any nonviolent
or non catastrophic interventions
ameliorating inequality
to any measurable degree.
And so,
well,
so that's what Google one is about.
Essentially.
I a lot of [inaudible] things
I didn't tell you are um,
part of the reason that I wrote it and
taking some humorous flack and some not
so humorous flack about the claims that
may not go to one because I talk about
lobsters and
the reason that I talk about
lobsters this cause I was reading,
I read a lot of animal
experimental psychology,
neuroscience,
that sort of thing,
basic neuroanatomy and
functional neuroanatomy,
brain chemistry.
I'm very interested in the really solid
biological end of psychology as well as
the more abstract clinical
psychological theory stuff.
Sort of two places I've drawn
the most of what I do from.
And uh,
I was reading some great papers about
crustacean nervous systems 15 years ago or
so.
And crustaceans have a pretty simple
nervous system compared to ours.
Fairly large neurons and so you
can back them up pretty well.
And I'm like a crustacean lobster.
It's a lot simpler than a
person neurologically speaking.
That's a pretty still pretty
damn complicated thing.
You know what I mean?
It believes autonomously and Hans
it can recognize friend and foe.
It can,
it knows where its burrow is.
Like it's,
it's got a very wide range
of complicated behaviors.
So you don't want to think
that that officers too simple.
I mean,
they've been around for somewhere
between 300 and 600 million years,
so,
you know,
in one form or another.
So they're doing just fine.
Anything that lasts that long,
he's not stupid
but monsters or organize themselves
into Iraq and while hierarchies,
the consequence of unequal distribution
of resources and essentially there's no
difference between those two things.
And um,
I was really interested in that because,
well,
because of the problem of hierarchy with
problem with inequality and the problem
just proportionate of production
and all of that and the fact that,
so I started to study the neurology
and the neuropsychology and the neuro
pharmacology of the systems in our
brains that govern our responses to
hierarchy.
And so this is another piece of
evidence that we can't lay hierarchy or
inequality or disproportionality apathy
of the political system because your
brain is so adaptive to hierarchy,
you cannot believe it.
So there are modules in your brain.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
Or more like the
underlying some structure,
like there's the foundational substructure
that's a third of a billion years
old,
which by the way is way older than treats,
but that's old.
You basically share it to the crustaceans.
So crustaceans have a
counter in their brain,
you know that's an oversimplification,
but it will do to have a counter in their
brain that tells them where they are
in the lobster higher.
And if there are one,
which means they're very
like low level lobsters,
then they're kind of timid
and they crunched down and
they sneak around and they
don't buy to draw much attention to
itself and they're easily startled.
And if they come up to another was to
don't tell fuck the hell out was their,
their,
their manager is better ignored and at
the bottom then dismembered and dead
natural cheese in general.
And then the lobsters as they move up,
say 10,
10 strata,
lost your hierarchy to get stretch out.
And they all cry more and more space.
So like two lobsters of equivalent size,
one who's a number one law one,
he's number 10 in Gloucester,
will occupy different amounts of area
because the number one Gloucester
stretches out.
It looks bigger than he is,
let's say,
because he's confident
because he's won all the time.
Whereas the number 10 blogs,
his French is down.
And so I thought that was very
interesting because I knew that there's an
analogy between human depression and
low physician in primary dominant car
instructors.
So on.
The analogy seems to be that what
happens when you get depressed?
Well,
sometimes if you're both status,
you're depressed.
But sometimes if you're depressed you act
like the low status even though you're
not.
And that's not a bad
definition of depression.
And it's actually a good way of thinking
about what's happening functionally in
a neuro chemically.
And so,
and then I was more so that was
interesting and I found out.
But at the same time that in the lobster,
the neurochemical Serotonin
is a fundamental chemical.
The serotonergic system is very,
very ancient.
And when you're in Utero,
when your brain is getting set up,
the serotonin system sets it up and
it regulates your Hoshin Serotonin.
So in some sense what it does is determine
how much positive emotion you feel
compared to how much
negative emotions and no,
those are separate systems by the way.
So happiness is not the
opposite of sadness.
There's a system for happiness and there's
a system for sadness and they inhibit
each other,
but it's not one system.
So you can have very high levels of
negative emotion and very high levels of
positive emotion.
So if you pick a big tribe and you read
behind neuroticism and you're really
high in extroversion,
that you're someone who has very high
levels of big and promotion and very high
end up with a positive voltage.
So that the APP,
what what Serotonin does is that
as your serotonin levels increase,
your sensitivity to negative emotion
increases and your sensitivity deposit
emotion decreases.
And so people hate that and no wonder,
right?
Like person hate that because all the
pleasure and hope goes away and all the
pain and the anxiety is magnified.
And that's proportionate to your
position and the dominance harder.
So as you move up your serotonin levels,
increasing stress out,
can you stand tall and proud of to say
and you're more susceptible deposit
motion hope and less
susceptible to negative emotion.
And as you plummet down
the dominance hierarchy,
which happens if you're defeated or
humiliated or embarrassed or or promotion
work that you were expecting our work,
well you've run into one of
those situations who life
where things fall apart on
you serve who levels fall through droops
and your negative emotion starts to get
out of control.
And so,
and the fact that that it's a staggering
thing that that physio chemical
response has be maintained
for third of appealing ears.
Right?
And I'm sure as you,
and also see it also helps you understand
why people don't like humiliation and
lots of people don't like to public speak.
It's one of the most common fears work
on then the fear of death by the way.
And the reason that we don't like to
public speak is because while you're,
you're in front of a hierarchical group
and exposed to the evaluation of the
group and people don't like that and
well just explained why people don't like
it when your belief systems
are challenged either.
And I thought about that for a long,
long,
long time.
And there's one second logical theory
that's called terror management theory.
The idea is that you have a belief system
to make sense of things in the world
and as long as it remains intact,
then Andrew can make sense
of things in the rules,
then you don't feel an overwhelming
sense of existential anxiety.
Some one comes along Marcus,
about the accidents of your belief system
and you don't have an explanation for
things that you get
overwhelmed by anxiety.
And that's why people play
for the belief systems.
But I have a,
and that is that um,
your,
your competence like okay,
so let's say by we university professor
hypothetically that means on the slotted
into a dominant hierarchy
ended up pretty high levels.
Like being a university professors.
Again,
good job.
You know,
because it's very secure,
which is a good thing and
it's very prestigious.
So that's also a good thing now so
I can see myself in that hierarchy.
And was your number two
or number three position,
whatever it happens to be somewhere
approximately close to the top.
And I have a claim hold that position now
I'm a moral claim on that position and
hypothetically,
and it's a position
that other people want.
So it's very competitive.
It's any attempt to
find a high status job.
It's extraordinarily competitive and it's
not surprising because the prestigious
positions,
they're secure and they're economically
advantageous so and they're scarce.
So of course there's competition.
So hypothetically you win some sort
of contest in order to deal with that
position also.
What would the content be?
It might be,
well I know enough to justify being put
in that position when someone stands up
and the question period say it puts
me on the spot and indicates that my
knowledge about something is less
thorough than I might have been claiming.
You might say,
well that's shaking.
My belief structure could more accurately.
I think Britney saves that.
We can my moral claim to the position
in the actual hierarchy that actually
protects me rather than the belief
system that I use to construe the world.
You know,
like being in an actual hierarchy,
slotted near the talk isn't only
psychologically adventageous,
right.
It's actually advantageous.
It actually is more secure.
It actually is Bernard's economic
benefits that come along with it.
It is a prestigious position.
None of that's merely psychological.
And so people don't like
having their competence,
their incompetence displayed in public
before their peers because it threatens
their [inaudible] to their position
in the hierarchy and that position
stabilizes their emotions.
And so that took about
25 years to figure out
a moral,
I guess the moral of the story is the
point of the story and point of the story
is the direction of the story and the
direction of the story has a moral
injunction because I'm more on junction
is go back way instead of that one.
Right.
Or maybe it's,
well it turns out that way is up.
That's actually more of a moral of junk
because my big ball and you'd like to
move up.
Well,
maybe you want to move down or who?
I wouldn't recommend that.
But when people do a mic down sometimes
like the kid in Florida yesterday,
right,
who was eating very seriously at
doubt and so people doing it down,
but you might think that
aiming it up is better,
but you might not know which way up there.
I said the moral of the story is a point
or two which way is up and each of the
rules in my book is a pointer to
which way is up and you know they're,
I wouldn't say the rules themselves,
particularly
unique or original.
I actually try to make them,
I know unique,
original and tried to make them rock solid
and obvious and then explain why they
were so necessary because
well generally speaking,
if something sort of self care then you
don't have much of a rationale for it.
You don't need it.
It's like,
well everyone knows that like well it
turns out you don't really know what you
just accept it because everyone else does.
And that's usually good enough.
So when in in 12 rules,
one of the things I suggested plus,
well you've got this problem of hierarchy,
right and the really catastrophic
consequences of failure and the
disproportionate advantages of success
and the stress that that puts on social
systems might say,
well we'll go for radical egalitarianism
but there's no evidence that that works
and plenty of evidence that
it has catastrophic outcomes.
And plus if you get rid of hierarchies
that you don't have any op cause one of
the advantages of a hierarchy as it says,
well a is better than B and you might say,
well if a is better than me,
then some people are better at a then
at the end then you get into quality.
But if nothing is better than
anything else than what the hell,
what do you,
why live,
right?
You've got to know you the way in.
If one thing is new better than another,
then you're not mistaking
depressed because he wants
to just sit there and age.
You know
what the Hell's the difference?
If everything is equal,
then there's no impetus for action.
This is actually a
technical truth by the way,
because we know how positive
emotion systems work.
We know a lot about them.
And I think the person who did the best
work on that was Jeffrey Gray who wrote
a book called the neuro psychology.
My anxiety,
which is on my reading list on my website,
but brilliant book,
it only take you about six months,
a four hour days to read.
He must've read 3000 scientific
papers to write that book.
And not only can he read them,
he actually read them
and the understood them.
You actually took the time to understand
that many synthesize them and then he
did an accurately and that's like,
that just never happens.
And so you just,
neuropsychology of anxiety has 20 years
of off rate geniuses work condensed into
300 pages and it's not something you can
just pick up and scan through because
every sentence is a learning experience.
But Ray did a really
nice job back in 1982.
Um,
and things have changed
to some degree since then,
but no law in laying out what the
function of the positive emotional system
while he was discussing the
neurological basis of anxiety.
It turns out that most of the positive
emotion that people experience is not as
a consequence of attaining a goal.
It's more a consequence of looking.
I'm noticing that you're moving forward
towards your goal that you desire.
So we have a system,
it's called Conservatory reward system
that makes you feel good when you get
something you want.
So for example,
if you sit down at Thanksgiving
and you eat the Turkey afterwards,
you're feeling satisfied.
So it's the satisfaction system.
You're fitting satisfied
and that's a kind of good,
but it's not excited,
hopeful ending,
engaged.
That's a whole different car
and that's a better seventh.
One of the motivations,
and we know about because people
preferentially like drugs that these,
that effect cocaine and amphetamine
methamphetamine does that.
Alcohol does that.
If you're predisposed to alcoholism,
it activates the second
motor exploratory system.
It's dope and dope at the near GP medium.
That's the dopamine system and the drugs
that people really like don't make you
feel satisfied.
So like do you sit around after
you've had a giant Turkey?
It make you feel like you're
doing something that makes
like life worth living.
And that's what cocaine does even know
cooking doesn't make like worthy of
provides that the simulation.
And so,
so the upshot of that is,
and this is a theme that is
woven throat 12 rules for life,
is that no goal,
no aim,
no op,
no hierarchy,
no positive emotion.
So that's,
that's something that we also were just
need to keep in mind cause hierarchies
have this terrible price strength,
which is the people
stock up with water by.
If there isn't a hierarchy of value,
so that one thing is better than another.
Well what the hell is all
your striking the floor?
And I think that it's
actually even worse than that.
And this is another
motif that could go to,
like people often ask,
does life have a meaning?
And that's actually a fairly chill,
formulated question because the
answer to that is self evidently yes.
What's the meaning?
Pain and anxiety.
Right.
And the reason I use
those to self evidence,
because even if you're a cynic,
like a nihilistic,
sending a hopeless nihilistic
Sinek that life has no meaning,
it's like you're wrong because
hold as you will to that theory,
you will still be in pain
and anxious and he might say,
well that's not a meaning.
It's like yeah actually it is
just happens to be negative,
but it's not neutral.
It's a meaning.
And so the question life meaning is more
like does life have meaning in spite of
its suffering?
And the answer that seems to be,
well it depends what you aim at
and if you don't need anything
then no is the answer.
And then the next dance was
something like you have to him.
And something that's so valuable that
the pursuit of it justifies the suffering
and the anxiety.
And so that actually means you need a
pretty damn steep hierarchy of values.
Some things have to be way better than
other things because otherwise there's
not enough force in their pursuit to
produce enough engagement in life to
overcome dot catastrophe of life.
And you might say,
well why we're coming to
catastrophe your life?
Well there's a bunch of answers to that.
One is well you'll be in your own little
hell if you don't and so unless that's
what you want and then
I wouldn't recommend it,
but that's only the beginning of things
and this is something 12 was like cause
in some way a very,
very dark book.
Like I make a very
chapter six for example,
which is put your house in
perfect order before you,
the size of the world.
There's a full explanation of what
happened yesterday in Florida.
No,
because I spend a lot of time to try to
figure out just exactly how is it that
you have to think for several months or
years in your Bruning obsession about
the structure of the world before you
decided that it's really a good idea to
pick up a 70 on a rifle,
semi automatic rifle and going into high
school and shoot a bunch of innocent
people or maybe worse.
You'd go in Connecticut
and it in high school.
Kids who shoot it's elementary school
kids just to put that extra Marin.
She Cherry on top of your
delightful confection of evil,
right?
Because high school kids,
but they'd probably done
at least something wrong.
It was elementary school kids,
they're getting as close the innocence
as you could cost cause damage.
And so if you're particularly negatively
inclined and you have your reasons,
then the most innocent target
is the most attractive.
And so if you want to understand that,
and you probably should,
even though you really don't want it,
then you can read chapter six because
I've tried very hard to put myself in hand
and people who do that sort of thing,
and I understand why they do it.
And part of it is a live lives that
are nothing but pain and anxiety.
And there's all sorts of reasons for that.
Sometimes it's bad luck,
sometimes it's neural chemical accidents,
sometimes until health is
often tied up with a fair edit,
let's call it moral psychopathology.
They don't see any positive meaning in
life that outweighs the catastrophe of
life and then become normally
immersed in their own little hell,
which is bad enough.
But eventually stewing in that hell leads
them to the inevitable conclusion that
distributing it as widely as possible
with as much may have as possible with as
much evil intent as can be managed in
the shortest possible period of time is
definitely the right thing to do and so
the thing is is that your food doesn't
collapse in the hierarchy of values.
Extract out what might be deposited,
meaning from your life,
which is bad enough.
It's sex you on the road,
it sets you on the road to hell.
That's the right way.
There isn't a prop.
There isn't a more accurate way of using
metaphorical language to describe that
pathway then that and that's why it's
part of what would you say the realization
that at the bottom of belief systems
at the bottom of the way that people
construe the world,
there are religious metaphors at some,
sometimes you need a level of analysis,
but it's so deep that there isn't anything
that suffices for the analysis except
that level of metaphorical language.
I certainly the case when
you're dealing with people like,
like mass shooters,
especially the ones that commit suicide
because that's what,
these are the floors too,
right?
Cause my take,
why not just shoot yourself at home and
save the rest of us all the God damn
trouble.
Right?
No seriously.
That's an important question.
That's a crucial question.
So like if you're,
if you're,
if you're done with your life,
why bother with the big display?
Who exactly are you trying to convince?
And a what now?
Some of it is that desire for post-talk
notoriety because there's a lot of
fantasizing can try.
It's that.
It's like,
well don't be sorry when this
common theme in suicidal fantasies,
especially if on adolescents there'll
be sorry they did acts to be witnessed,
happens when they see my,
you know,
cold body in the coffin or,
or when they see the
mayhem that I produced.
But more it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a quick group to notoriety status
as we've already discovered this very
important to people.
And if you can't get
into in a positive way,
then well you know what was
given to me a negative way.
And so you know,
when we do ourselves a great disservice
by publishing the names of the shooters
and maybe at some point we become
mature enough not to do that.
But it doesn't look like that time is now.
And sort of these people
are also very competitive.
You know,
it's not like one shooter doesn't
know what the previous one was.
Knockin
so in rural one I also talk about how
to deal with this on equal landscapes.
You know,
and I make a case about maybe you'd
be bullied when you were a kid,
but some high you're liking,
cause everyone's pulling me as a kid,
but maybe boy more than normal.
You know,
you are a continual part of the employee
that's kind of traumatized students.
So you're not as upward
with it as you might think.
It's like,
well what do you do about that?
Well hopefully you can remove yourself
from the circumstances that obtained when
you were being bullied.
That happens often to people as they
mature because you're much more likely to
be bullied as a kid that
you are as an adult,
you know?
So sometimes it just maturation.
We'll get that.
But you still might
carry the scars of your,
of your
experiences with being unfair and Goldman
or why you stretch yourself back up.
You do that physically and physically
and then a physical element is something
like,
well first it's a recognition that see
the kids who do these terrible things,
a very annoyed yet the way the world is
structured because the world contains a
tremendous amount of suffering and they
often regard themselves as hopefully you
call rebellious advocates of protest
against the suffering of the world.
If you read the by your kids notes,
you'll see that jump the judges of being,
I think that because being is
contaminated with suffering,
if 11 months that it should be eradicated,
that's the central theory.
Um,
they,
we allow their own
suffering to embetter them.
I guess that's the right
way thinking about it.
And it's understandable,
right?
That's the thing is that because life is
hard and some people really have heart
bucks,
you know,
like almost everyone
has a pretty hard life.
You get right down.
I'm ready to talk.
People have hard lives.
You know you have $100 million,
but your father's dying.
It's like it's great that you're rich,
but you know your father's going to hell.
It's fine.
There's nothing to do with almost
everyone has gotten an ongoing tragedy in
their own personal life as an individual
or is typing associated with someone
who does and there's not much we can
do in some ways to protect ourselves
against that material.
Wealth alone,
just like it's better than poverty,
but there's many things.
It just doesn't address many
of the most fundamental things.
There's every reason to become admitted,
but the problem is is if
you becoming better to them,
everything that makes you bitter gets
worth that seems to be able to bad
solution.
I spent a lot of times,
some of you might have listened to my
biblical lectures on cane enabled because
that's the story of Cain and Abel.
Cain gets bitter and he's angry at God
because of the structure of the universe.
No mongers,
you know,
less time up as having none
of us basically tells Kane.
Then if he used everything that was in
front of him to its proper advantage,
then the world that he wouldn't have,
it would no longer be characterized
by an unbearable suffering.
You know,
one of the things that I've learned
from reading the biblical stories among
other things and,
and the clinical literature,
I would say,
is that there's really
something to that idea.
You know,
and I said the 12 rules for
life is a very dark book.
You know,
because plays up in no uncertain terms.
The idea of a,
that life is characterized by suffering,
that's a universal truth,
suffering,
pain and anxiety.
To put it more in a more
differentiated manner.
And at that painting,
suffering is enough to embitter you.
And understandably so.
So that's the dark status quo,
let's say.
But then the next question would be,
what do you have any arm
movements against that?
Right?
What do you use in your struggle
against tragedy and evil?
And
while that's courage
and truth and courage,
that's partly posture.
You know,
cause when you stand up and
expose yourself and you've
exposed the parts of you
that you're most vulnerable
to confidence stamps,
it's like how bad or you know,
come acne.
And that's the attitude to the world.
It's combat,
it's downs,
but not just that.
It's also a trusting stance in some sense,
right?
Cause the Hydra people means
that you don't trust them on,
I've learned something,
something too about the difference
between nine eva take now you've trust and
trust.
So like a child who's naive
thinks everyone is good and
then maybe we'll become,
be traded her guest.
The consequences of naive and
everyone was good and so trust,
but that's not trust.
That's just naive.
And it's not a virtue.
Even though it trusting
child was a lovely thing.
It's not a virtue.
It's just the absence of
experience with betrayal.
So we'll like,
once you're an adult teenager,
like say you've been hurt,
you've been betrayed,
why should you trust and answer is
never because people are trustworthy.
That's the wrong answer.
The right answer is because
you're a courageous.
That's the right answer.
And so you meet people
with an attitude of trust,
knowing what can go wrong,
but the willing to take
that as a necessary cost of
potentially bringing out the
best in the other person and in you.
And I would say,
I would also say that the empirical data
on the utility of that as an approach
is also quite staggering with the high,
some of the best analysis of what
makes countries rich versus poor,
but indicated that the
level of interpersonal trust
and the country is a great
predictor of economic don't
believe economic success
but probability of economic
growth.
And you can understand why that is is
like how the hell are you going to train
with someone without accruing enforced
and costs that will completely obliterate
the utility of the train
unless you trust them.
Like if I can trust you,
I don't have to know anything about you.
I don't have to know how
full snakes you actually are.
It doesn't matter cause you simplify
yourself down with your word and then we
can interact cooperative.
And so I really think that
the only natural resource,
apart from intelligence,
perhaps his trucks and the
trust is actually a consequence
of courage and not of
naivety when it's matured.
And I help my clients
with that idea a lot.
I mean it's not exactly,
I read the works of most of the
brake conditions of the 20th century.
So I've learned a tremendous amount from,
you know,
from reading what they have to say.
And that idea of courageous
trust is a really,
that's an unbelievably powerful,
especially when you're doing,
he might think behind,
not neat,
naive,
I'm not going to trust people.
It's like,
yeah,
fair enough.
That makes you not naive.
That's step one.
Now you step one,
not naive,
that step to not,
not even willing to trust,
that's day three.
Right?
And that opens the world.
That's to Q again say,
will you voluntarily take on the fact
that you're vulnerable and that life is
tragic and that it's
tainted by malevolence.
You accept that and then you decided to
move forward and do good despite that.
And well I don't.
And,
and so part of the conclusion
in 12 rules for life,
although not stated no
as a formal conclusion,
is that terrible as tragedy is and tainted
by malevolence as life is truth and
courage are stronger
than pain and despair.
And I actually think that's true.
I think it's true.
Literally you see,
you see this in psychotherapy.
So if someone comes to you and they
have like paralyzing levels of anxiety,
you cannot give you the house.
They're agoraphobic.
So they're terrified of being in
an elevator and getting stuck.
They're afraid.
What the really afraid
of and an elevator is,
they'll often,
people who have anger phobia are
afraid that they'll have a heart attack
somewhere.
They can't get to the hospital.
So then they get afraid of
anywhere that they might go away,
they couldn't get to the hospital quickly.
And so that will be taxis,
especially in a busy street.
Subways,
theaters telemeers getting in places
where they might get trapped and their
thoughts are if often
having heart palpitations or
someone close to them died of
a heart attack or they have to have
any history of heart disease or they've
recently been through a divorce and being
very anxious because of that and are
more cognizant that the hotel anyway,
they have got reasons to start becoming
anxious and then being avoid places that
they might get trapped in that they
get more and more anxious and fighting.
They can't even leave their house.
And so when you treat someone like that,
you don't make them less afraid
because it's too damn late for that,
you know,
they're naive to begin with.
This is often the case with,
it's usually women who felt anger phobia.
They've often be over protected by the
fondant or the boyfriend or the husband
or whatever have you,
and then something comes along that they
can't be protected from like some hint
of mortality or the possibility of
divorce and they become extraordinarily
anxious to come see a therapist.
Therapist has any sense.
It doesn't say,
why don't we,
what you're anxious about?
It says,
well,
of course you're anxious,
so I could s what are you staggering
that everyone is terrified?
One scholar was open the time,
like why are people anxious?
What a stupid question that
like really wanting phalanges.
Yeah.
One of the people drink.
I don't think I can answer for that.
Why don't people take,
okay,
no wrong question,
right.
Question is why don't they take it all
the time to the exclusion of all else?
It's like we know why people take,
okay.
It's perfectly all of this.
And so the question with anxieties,
how is it that some people aren't
anxious some of the time and with the
agoraphobic,
the issue is,
well,
how do you bring in state that now that
they've come to confrontation with their
own vulnerability is mortality.
That's basically the issue.
There's no holding back.
You know,
maybe the person who says,
well,
I've got her qualifications.
I have a family history of heart disease.
It's like I'm sure a terrified.
It's like,
how does nothing,
you probably won't have a heart attack.
Oh,
hey,
thanks.
[inaudible].
Once that specter of here,
this in front of you,
probability is irrelevant.
Most of what did you do is you teach
people to live in spite of them.
You teach them to be courageous,
not to be,
not afraid.
You teach them to be brave.
And the way you do that is you show
them that there's more to them than they
thought.
So you know when you do this
with behavioral exposure,
for example,
so let's say you want to
take an agoraphobic doesn't
mean an elevator for three
years.
And so you know,
maybe they work on the 15th floor.
This is actually an,
they're getting older.
It's actually a problem,
right?
You got to take the down elevator
and there's a whole complex of fears
associated with the elevator.
So you say,
well,
you know,
what are you afraid of?
And they say,
well,
I'll have a heart attack.
That elevator stop all get stuck,
all panic on a heart attack and die and
there'll be 300 people in the elevator
and they'll make a fool
of myself while I'm dying.
And no point in being black
because it's social humiliation.
If people hate plus death.
And so you get those two together,
you ever read walloping
fear of complex going,
I'm going to die slowly and stupidly.
Well,
lots of people are gathered
around watching it.
So,
so I,
I had for agoraphobic client.
So the way you treat someone
like that and you say,
okay,
well let's,
let's pick some,
write down the 10 things you're really
afraid of with number one being the thing
you're most afraid of,
a number 10 minutes,
something you're pretty afraid of.
And so let's say they list elevators.
His numbers would say,
okay,
we're going to start with number 10
because we're not going to make this any
more difficult for you.
Then that's,
then you say,
look,
there's,
there's no tricks to this.
You've done it in the
first guys to trust you.
I treated some of them with a needle
phobia while bathroom and this person has
needle phobia that was so intense that
he would have dental surgery without
anesthesia.
So,
right,
right.
So we know that's the
definition of whether not,
you know,
I brought a needle into the office and
I told him a week before I'm going to
bring an evening into the office and it's
going to be sitting on the shelf right
there and when you come in next week
I'll show it to you and you'll know where
it gets cause you don't muck
about with your clients.
They have to know exactly what's going on.
And then when I did the cameras practice,
I let him practice leaving.
I said because I want you to,
if you're a neutral with this,
that was the rule and
you're in control this,
I'm going to pick up that Amigo but not
until I tell you and if you want me to
stop at any time I will stop and if you
want to leave at anytime you can just
leave it.
I'm going to get your
fear if you leave it.
And so I haven't practiced
like 10 times how,
let me just stop and leave
it because just telling me,
telling him that it wasn't enough.
It's kind of like practicing something
with pretending to play with the child,
right?
To act it out with them.
It's better than just to tell them,
because you get to know if
you have children by the way.
So I let them practice that,
like tender,
tell him he was bored with it,
no new drill was right.
And then,
you know,
I'd say,
well,
I'm going to pick up this needle
now I'm going to four inches.
And Norman one kind.
You go look at it,
you have to look at it.
That's the thing that
you got to look terrible,
right?
And then you dissociated from all the
terrible things you imagine if my feet,
and so it took about six sessions,
something like that before he could
go to the hospital and had a needle,
you feel,
but okay.
But what happened,
you see,
wasn't that he got less afraid of
needles is that he got braver about,
yeah.
So now,
so the first one,
we have to be elevated problems.
So this is what happens.
So you say,
well look,
how about looking at some pictures
of elevators and they say,
yeah,
I think I can handle that.
Or maybe they don't.
Maybe that's enough to say,
okay,
well let's look at a hundred
pictures of elevators.
You'll get bored of it
sooner or later and so,
and you want to get bored of it
because if you're bored or something,
you're not anxious about it.
So it's like,
well,
here's a picture of an elevator.
How are you feeling when all,
you know,
I can feel my heart rate accelerating
and I'm breathing more heavily.
It's like,
okay,
we'll just keep looking at
it until that stops it stop.
If the person doesn't run away,
that was talk in five minutes or so
because anxiety system sees the logic,
it makes all and it scans to see if
anything additionally terrible happens and
if answer is no,
then shuts down.
But if the answer is you run away
and the anxiety assistant things,
well that must be a Predator of some
sort because otherwise why would you run
away?
And so it gets a creditor then
you're afraid of it and running away.
And makes you more afraid.
So just wait it out.
Then you're making an event,
the thing you were afraid of,
that's what you're teaching yourself.
And so then maybe we'll take pictures
and then you take them in the hallway and
you say,
see that elevator over there?
Can you stand me this close
to it and say no or yes.
And if it's knowing,
say well we'll 10 feet farther back,
whatever.
You stand there watching
the and close for awhile.
Just imagine that you're near watching.
It's like you have to want to do that.
Keep your eyes focused on it,
going to look at,
we'll just feed that to your board.
It doesn't take very long.
Then you move closer to nine
five posts and then fly.
Keep closer to sooner than they think.
Almost inevitably they're like right
up on the elevator and you say,
well we'll let the doors open.
You would give you a quick look inside.
That would be enough for the day,
so it's fine.
So then they come back the next time
and maybe the next time you say,
okay,
look,
we're going to start a little
back from where we were.
They have to be on here.
I'm in a hole,
opened the door,
and you just put your head
inside and look around.
Look at,
look at the corners,
look at the numbers,
make sure you're bloody
know it where you are.
Is it an elevated Kenny do that?
Yes.
And he's like three sessions,
something like that.
You can get the person going down.
Wonderful Gentlemen speaking.
Now the cycle of analysts believe that
if you get behavioral treatment of a
phobia like that,
the phobia would just reappear somewhere
else because they thought the full view
of represented something deeper,
like fear of death,
which it actually does.
But it turns out that if you do
behavioral exposure like that,
people
bravery generalizes the the
doesn't bravery generalizes.
So one of the things that's commonly
reported among women who are treated track
your whole game is that they start
to fight with their husbands.
We convert the tendon
right there dependent.
They don't want their husband
to leave because they're afraid.
And so because they're
dependent and afraid,
they won't put forward what they want.
So then if you teach them that they're
actually tough enough to go into an
elevator despite being terrified of dying,
which is actually a pretty good
thing to learn about yourself,
right?
It's like,
oh,
the professor,
I can move forward,
just write the faculty chair.
Point of dying can actually
still move forward.
It's like there's a hell of a
lot more to me than I thought.
Once you know that,
then you can give in the taxi and you
can take the bus and you can tell your
husband what the hell you wanted
to tell him for the last 15 years.
Disruptions are secondary
to the treatment,
you know?
So the thing is is that courage
generalizes and people can be unbelievably
courageous.
And funny thing is,
is you don't know that
until you put yourself in a
situation where it's demanded
of me.
And so I had another client who I,
who was afraid of life,
that's really the truth.
And I took her to an embalming.
No.
And she was so afraid of death that
she couldn't go into a butcher store.
So you know,
in a bunch of store,
well you think that's pretty,
if you really take them out,
it's pretty damn protest place.
I mean it's,
it's a place of death.
Obviously you're blind to
them or be put in the reason.
But she wasn't too,
this is a place of death.
I'm not going there.
And
the consequences of that fear,
we're radically and destroyed her life.
And she had a dream that indicated
that if she didn't learn to live in the
slaughter house,
she would,
she wouldn't survive.
That's basically the shows,
the grievant we've boiled that down to,
I asked her what,
what could we do that would be
equivalent in some sense to visiting a
slaughterhouse?
Cause that seemed to be on the question.
She said,
well I'd like to see him in bombing
the hell it was going to arrange that.
But it turns [inaudible] partner and you
tell the people there and if you have
someone who's terrified of death and that
they need to do something about that,
that people who work in the funeral parlor
fraction point dealing with that and
then people would work
there in incredible they do.
They deal with death all the time,
right?
All the time.
They deal with death and grief
all the time and they do it.
It's unbelievable what they can do that
and people who will tell you a terrible
words do that for people who work in
emergency words and people who are
paramedics there like facing this,
why do you castrophe just never now
in a never ending parade calamity.
And they do it.
It's like people are pretty damn tough.
You know,
so,
so that's a pretty remarkable thing.
And so see,
I need to get past with one tonight.
So
I guess each of the rules in the booker,
the time contain each other,
each other rules.
That's one way of thinking about the
motifs are quite similar as we worked in
the choppers and the fundamental motif
of the book is something might go wrong.
What I just laid out is that
this is a message of optimism.
And I actually think this is why so
many people are watching my lectures.
As far as I can tell,
I'm a dark guy,
man,
and I have a really optimistic idea,
you know,
because I've spent my whole,
life's got in the worst possible things
that people can do to each other.
And you're are things that people do
meet each other that are so bad that you
just cannot,
you can't even imagine it.
And that's a rough thing to say
because like we have kind of a logical
imaginations.
And if you let those some things cycle,
you can imagine it's a
pretty dreadful things.
But believe me,
there are things that people
have done to each other that,
that a normal person
could not imagine do it.
And there are things I've read,
especially about what happened when the
Japanese invaded China in World War Two
because are so dark that you can't read
them without being permanently affected
by it.
And you know,
I've helped lots of people through very
difficult periods of their lives and
spend a lot of time studying totalitarian
atrocity on the right and the left,
it's like,
it's pretty damn harsh,
you know?
But what I've come out and from
that [inaudible] Carl Young,
new something,
his Motif,
it was an l chemical,
a little team fee derived from
the study about him helping me.
I was up lacked.
It's a lot to move teeth instruct
William has been given a tour,
which means that which you most need will
be filed where you least want to look.
And that's a hell of a tank.
That's the barrier to
enlightenment because they think,
well perhaps even could be enlightened.
Well,
what stopped me following your
bliss as Joseph Campbell said,
um,
I guess he revised that.
I've heard that the other day.
Who a follow your blisters just actually
said that knowing that you may be
glossed over the problem a bit too Glib,
but that wasn't the Carl,
you don't it.
Our idea was even new thing.
Do what's meaningful.
And truthfully we'll take
him to do some really,
really dark places and that was
straightened you the hell out.
And that's about right.
And so what I found by investigating
the darkness was that it clarified the
light at the same time.
It makes sense,
right?
Because it makes sense.
How could you understand good and
you've got to understand that evil.
And if you don't think there's evil though
and God help you because one day and
they will tear you into pieces.
And that happens to people far
more frequently than you think.
In my clinical experience,
I've never seen someone with posttraumatic
stress post traumatic stress disorder
who hadn't encountered people.
That's what causes post traumatic
stress disorder is a trauma.
Kids fall and break the makes.
They don't get post
traumatic stress disorder.
You,
you,
you're naive on some part of your
life and you hit someone who's MLevel.
Maybe it's you,
because that's often across
a posttraumatic stress
disorder to among soldiers in
particular,
they watched themselves to a sub doing
something they cannot imagine that they
could do and they do it.
They never recovered from that.
So,
so we know the world is a tragic place
and it's a level of place and we each
have our personal tragedy in our
family tragedy and reach carriers of
malevolence and,
and,
and recipients,
Sukkot.
And that's the landscape
of reality in a sense.
But there are,
there are modes of conducting yourself
in the world that are more powerful then
tragedy and evil and
those involved courage.
So that's the first thing that the courage
is something like the willingness to
voluntarily take on the burden of the
tragedy and the level to accept it rather
than to fight it,
except as a condition of being.
It's something like that.
You have to accept it
as a condition of being.
Um,
I read this really interesting
old Jewish all monetary years ago.
I don't even remember the source,
but it was one of the most brilliant
things I've ever read that the commentator
was discussing.
The classical attributes of God,
omniscience,
omnipotence,
omnipresence,
so that's everything.
Fundamentally,
the question was what does it being,
it's omniscient,
omnipresent,
and omniscient.
Black and obvious answers.
Nothing.
That's not the correct answer.
The correct answer is a limitation.
That's so amazing.
That's an amazing thing is that limitation
has advantages that totality lacks
limitation in,
so something to struggle against.
Limitation Needs.
There's a place to go.
There's an op,
there's a story,
here's an adventure.
All of that requires an invitation,
not it's life.
It's an,
it's an adventure of sorts and
it's like it's a terrible venture.
It's a high stakes adventure because
you're all in and down whether you like it
or not.
You're all in.
That's the adventure.
Then the question is,
what is it worth it and then the crest,
the answer that might be
looked depends on the quest,
right?
Maybe that's the answer.
It's like if the quest is sufficient,
then the adventure is worth it.
And so that's the only optimistic talk
that I've ever come across that actually
believe
that could be true.
It seems like that if,
if you live that out,
you're like,
you know,
sometimes you have these where you
pick off was really worthwhile.
Anything.
What does that mean?
Well,
despite the terrible preconditions of Ba,
that seemed to announce
itself as valuable.
Okay,
well what if that was your
pursuit periods you can file.
I'm going to pursue what I regard
as the most valuable thing,
going to dedicate myself towards that
so that I have the adventure of my life
that justifies the suffering
of my life and the malevolence.
That's part and parcel of part and parcel
of the discuss the aim so far up that
the trip is worthwhile.
There's absolutely every reason to believe
that that's a proper answer like it
looks like it is.
What would be great stories say,
oh,
that's what the great efforts to say.
That's what the archetypes demonstrate.
That's what the neurobiology suggests.
That's what our agenda is,
to produce political structures that
are stable and relationships that work
suggested because you treat
each other in a relationship.
Because if,
if you love someone,
you treat that person as if the
adventure of their life is worthwhile.
If something like that,
he wouldn't love him.
If he didn't think that would do,
you would,
if you didn't think it was
worthwhile for them to be,
you would love them.
And so it's,
it's a judgment call you make.
It's like,
well it seems to me that it's
a big time for everybody.
Wake up and realize that life is
terrible and worse than you can possibly
imagine.
The history,
absolutely mad house tasks,
but the nobility of the human spirit
and the power of courage and truth is
sufficient to to transcend all of that.
And I think that's true individually,
like in the confines of your own life.
I think it's true for your family because
you can have a beneficial effect on
your family.
I think it's true for you in
relationship to the community.
And I have a sneaking suspicion now and
this is when my thought goes beyond its
ability to justify itself because it's
more of an intermission or founded
tuition,
but you can set yourself together so well
and if you start pulling other things
outside of the family and the
community together properly around it.
So they started to line up so that
everything starts to alignment,
Blaine up and come together
like something symphonic.
And we don't understand the relationship
between consciousness and reality very
well.
Cause obviously you're a
reciprocal relationship and
it's possible that each of
us play a much more fundamental role in
the structure of being than any of us
really realize.
We're certainly,
we certainly are far more
than we can understand.
What the hell do we know about themselves?
What's important help to get?
It's just like,
what are we exactly.
Well I'd be fun to find out
and the alternative seems
to be some bit of Kale and
so you know why not a,
so it's probably a good place to stop.
And we say,
well why the hell not eight months?
That
would be really good.
And I think everybody's ready for it.
So let's let you go do it.
Truth and courage.
That would be a good thing.
So thank you.
[inaudible]
never talked your mom.
So when you go in front of a crowd in
silence until everyone from little bit
wondering,
okay,
so
you won't know whether it be
do to the questions.
We can have more room.
That's where you have to drink.
[inaudible]
there have been moments
where I've had brief spells,
sort of bliss
and it's really easy for me to be
cynical because when I'm there I'm always
looking at people and think,
oh it's just switching.
It's found a good wave or
something like that.
But there might be
something where it's like,
it's like a dark spot on the map.
And so I was wondering more generally,
how can you distinguish between a cave
that's empty and became the head of the
dragon in it and also what
you've generally three to
buy my books [inaudible]
books,
they're more of a microcosm,
probably generally in favor of the
dangerous mean alcohol is dangerous
and sex is dangerous and all of that,
but we can't regulate any of that too
tightly because pending regulation it's be
more dangerous than the danger.
That's the big girl.
One possible solution to that
is
there's a chapter in this book,
this chapter can be
precise in your speech,
and it was a fun chapter,
Greg,
because it's a
description of how what you're aiming
app determines your world and I didn't
want me,
and that's kind of a metaphor you know,
is to lead,
for example,
the reality that you wouldn't have
heard is Maya or illusion that you're
suffering as a consequence of
being mired in that illusion.
And there's some real
truth to that because
one does determine how
the world manifest itself.
No,
it's not the only determinant,
you know,
because we really are
limited in some ways,
right?
We can bouncing along.
Quite happy with leaving everything,
right?
No,
there's an earthquake in
that telling falls on you.
And that's the exact,
so what can you founded
by your mortality of,
within that you have,
what would you say?
You have a landscape shorts and then
the way that landscape manifests itself
isn't no trivial manner
determined what you're aiming at.
So there's a story in that chapter,
but this woman,
she needs
a psychiatrist at a party,
if I remember correctly from a play
called the car feel party by DSL.
Yeah.
She tells the psychiatrist that
her life is going very well,
but she's suffering and you know,
thinking dark thoughts about how terrible
things are and she's hoping that he
could help her.
But before
she gets to that,
she says,
I really hope there's something
wrong with 10 the sidecar just says,
well,
what do you mean?
What do you,
why do you hope there's
something wrong with him?
Because she says,
well look,
I'm suffering badly.
And as far as I can tell,
there's only two possible
reasons for that.
One is something wrong with the world.
And I'm just stuck with that
and hence the suffering.
Or maybe there's something wrong with
me and that would be way better because
then I get both.
I'm not going to fix the world.
I can pull cash.
We fixed me.
And in some of the suffering that go away,
it's like,
and then when I read that,
I also thought about what
happened repeatedly in the
old testament because what
happened to the old testament repeatedly
is that the Israelites kind of get
their act together.
You know,
we sort of get things going.
Then they get all arrogant,
started breaking roles,
and then God comes along and just
walks them centuries lacking.
Then they gonna slowly get
themselves off the floor,
climb up again,
and then they get all arrogant.
They're flat and again.
But what's really interesting is
for the rise in the flatmates,
which is kind of part and parcel of life,
but the Israelites to response to that,
which is always to blame
themselves and not go up.
That's one of the things that makes that
book so unbelievably rock solid as the
hazard lights always think no catastrophe
because we didn't do things great
catastrophe because we
didn't do things right.
It's like even if that's not true,
yes it is true,
but even if it's not true,
it's like it's pretty good attitude.
It's a pretty good attitude to have.
It's like,
well you know even I have noticed this
when people are negotiating with their
partner to say it's like if you're
having a real dispute with your partner,
one really effective technique is to
separate cause like you have this dispute,
you're trying to hammer
each other's like separate,
go sit on a bed somewhere and think,
okay,
despite the fact that I'm married to the
most annoying person in the world and
in this instance,
is there anything that I've done no
matter how trivial in the last months that
have made this stupid
situation or probable.
And like if you ask
yourself that question,
take about 15 seconds to figure out other
dumb things you've done the optimum,
they'll come forward pretty
much in a never ending stream.
If people tell your partner,
you know,
yeah,
I'm not very far with you at the
moment and for sure you're wrong,
but here's some really
stupid things I've done.
Then they're,
they tend to be a lot happier
with you if you do the same thing.
We tend to be a lot happier with them.
So there's some utility in figuring out
what it is that you're doing to muck up
the situation.
So one of the things I would say with
regards to the nightclub situations,
maybe it's miserable because what you
want when you go there isn't right.
And so what I would say like,
and if we were talking about
this in a therapy session,
like I would say,
well let's,
let's lay out what it is
that you're searching for.
When you go there and you could write,
you'd have to kind of write approximations
because you might not actually know.
You kind of have some idea,
but you wouldn't exactly know.
It's okay,
let's figure out what
it is that you're after.
That's great.
You got a bunch of things that
you could be after otherwise.
And then let's send you to the nightclub
and 10 times and with these different
attitudes in mind and see what happens.
That's called collaborative
empiricism by the way.
It's a behavioral technique
and it's a good one.
So I would say,
well vary your approach.
You know,
maybe your approach wasn't,
I could meet to well to,
to you know,
to dance 30% more than you usually would.
You'd have to leave everything out of it.
Everything else out of it,
right?
It can't be,
well,
I'm trying to find a partner for
casual sex and that's really my end,
but I'm going to pretend that my aim
is to dance like 30% no wrong jack,
you haven't played the game strength
or maybe it's to have three engaging
conversation.
So if you could quantify it like that
and it's kind of trait in some sense,
but you're obviously not a pro at the
nightclub while you're on this mission
because it's not working out
for you the way and didn't mind.
So are you're saying change
your goals and see what happens.
So because perhaps what to pursuing
there isn't the right thing to pursue.
It's highly grown,
right?
[inaudible]
I'd like,
it isn't obvious what you
should be pursuing them,
but then I would say it's true.
It's because,
and I was very complex landscape,
right?
It's uh,
it's amazing the mark and it's,
it's accelerating.
Maybe market some sense.
You might say,
well,
what's on the optimal behavior and the
landscape that's an accelerator mating
market.
Well that's,
you can think about that for five years.
The pickup harvest types are
trying to figure that out too,
but because they felt they
knew is manifesting a persona
that's associated with
success in a rapidly
accelerated meaty market,
but they're not doing the real thing.
You know,
basically dance Lou more
complicated than that,
but
they're probably pursuing your goal that's
higher than like covering at home in
your basement covered the cheeto
dust [inaudible] suspicion for it.
It's still a sub optimal ethical pursuit.
[inaudible]
as you can see,
this,
this might work doesn't sound like,
as you can see,
I'm President Donald J.
Trump or as you might not know,
I'm Trump fake epi.
So I was born in 1946 older than you.
So,
but you might be able to help.
In my quest,
in my book,
the art of the deal,
I talked about how I'm
not just talking to him,
I'm trying to bring people
together from where they are.
It sounds like you've
done that in your packets.
So here's our big challenge.
If you could help me with that,
how are we going to end
the war between the sexes?
I have an idea how to start off because
you did mention breastfeeding and one of
your speeches I saw in,
and right now that's an unpaid labor,
so [inaudible] paid to breastfeed for a
start I think would be so angry at us,
man.
[inaudible]
to,
and that's for native to the sexual
harassment question and that's what I've
seen in question.
Then it does.
Looking at all of this,
which is,
you know,
we're trying to pull everyone's
talents into the general marketplace,
let's say flux and there's
some real utility in mountain.
It seems stupid to not use
intelligence of half the population.
And I guess that's kind of what we
decided with the invention of reliable on
birth control.
It was sort of a collective decision
that if we could free women from the
inevitability of nonstop magic maternity,
that that might be a
net benefit to everyone.
Now women is true.
We don't know because the experiments
only me running for 40 years.
But you might think,
well it was an experiment with running
and then the sexual revolution on that.
We're still in the throes of that.
Is it consequence as far as I'm concerned,
the introduction of the birth control
pill because that's a biological
revolution of,
you know,
I think the 20th century will
be remembered for hydrogen bomb.
The microprocessor
and the birth control for those are the
three big technological revolutions.
The question is,
well,
how should men and women act
towards each other in the workplace?
And answer that as well.
We don't,
no,
no.
How to regulate our sexual
behavior in the workplace.
Um,
I think it has,
these are,
these are deeply ethical questions,
big ethical question of what were you
doing when you go to the nightclub?
They think,
well that's not a deep ethical question.
It's like,
yeah and it's,
it's cause they get actually
cause you're asking them,
well how should I repeat it?
My sexual behavior when
I have choices matter.
And it's the same thing in the workplace.
You miss most in most
situations like this.
I'm a traditionalist because I actually
think that the best solution to the
problem about to the multiple problems
that life throws at you is a stable
monogamy.
I think the evidence for that,
it's overwhelming now.
Exactly how you parameterize that.
What leeway you allow people
within that framework.
Well enough wise enough to know.
I think you deviate from that path at
your peril and that we deviate from that
path as a society apparel as well.
And so
I just would say if you're
looking for a cheap thrill
and do you think that you could find
that insects that you're sadly mistaken.
That's what it looks like to me.
And I think that if people were willing
to accept that idea and I can certainly
understand why no one wants to
proceed in the workplace,
can start to tap themselves down quick
about one of the things I tell my younger
clients in particular,
cause you know back in the
1950s I wasn't around him,
but let's say the 1960s,
um,
the default answer to the question,
will you sleep with animals and
know and that's pretty good default.
And now it's not so obvious
that that is the deep,
even though I think it shouldn't be.
But here's a rule of thumb.
Is it useful one,
when you're trying to
figure out how the events,
your sexual interaction with
frozen new relationship,
how about you don't do anything physically
with anyone that you wouldn't talk to
them about it first.
I don't mean active consent.
I think that whole idea is a fabrication
of delusional 13 year old girl
[inaudible] because Mike
is a lot more stuff.
But I do think that a good rule because
something like no physical intimacy or
the corresponding emotional intimacy.
And I think the reason for that is
because you just can't traction.
If I could come as a package and I,
I think that you've been
fractionated off your functions,
let's say at your psychological peril.
So
now that's a pretty vague answer,
unfortunately,
all encompassing question,
right?
So you're going to get a vague answer
to an all encompassing question.
I also wrote a little bit about that
at the end of the 12 rules for life.
When I'm talking about the architect,
the architectural know,
the architectural representations of
human beings in the Christian domain,
the archetypal representation of a woman
is a virgin with the chocolate and the
archetypal representation of a man.
It's a crucified heal.
And those are all some
pretty decent representation.
They're overwhelming,
powerful,
you know that because they wouldn't
last several thousand years.
The code heavy wonder,
well how well globally the crucifixion
image is an image of the voluntary except
as the suffering and death and the
possibility that's transcendent and the
virgin mother is something like that.
The pristine totality of the feminine
and the and the and the feminine in
conjunction with the infant.
And those are holding images.
And then I would say that if you're
not treating each other like you're a
manifestation of that whole the image,
then you're not treating each
other property might say,
well that's a pretty high,
you know,
that's an extreme demands.
Like well that's okay.
Life makes experience.
There's nothing about 20 extremes of
the reason that those are images exist
is because they reflect a reality that
can't be transcendent,
something like that.
And so you violate them at your peril.
So
it's a little rough that
have to do,
here's some big band.
I am doing research on plasticity.
I read normally
if you're forward vocals and I
was just wondering why your costs,
the CV search as it got
me the streaming engine,
that sense of
psychologists boxes.
Um,
well I think that it is talked about but
I would say it's talked about more on
the biological end of the spectrum,
like convinced studies of neuroplasticity,
especially at the,
the capital level for a
very long period of time.
But then I would also say probably because
it's more of a medical concern that
it is a psychology concerns specifically.
So that was about,
it's also very complicated field,
but it's more psychologists.
Unless you go to a clinical school,
most of the psychology you take is
direct from the experimental realm.
So it's not concerned with medical
issues to such a great degree.
There is plenty of study done on,
on neuro transformations that
occur as a consequence of learning.
So,
but not so much with regards to neural
plasticity as a treatment that just or
exploitation of
neuroplasticity as a treatment,
which is what Norman was concentrating on.
So I think it is more at a
micro level among psychologist,
but it's very,
you just have to look into more of the
physiological end of the literature
rather than straight forward.
Second logical,
this isn't much of a question.
More of a thank you.
Uh,
two weeks ago I wouldn't be able changing
when I walked in the Nasdaq and 25 to
your diverse,
we're sitting around and watching the
electric line equity base politics and
what we're facing right now.
Um,
and additionally,
first by from unit,
um,
your explanation archetypes and most
amount of stress disorder for a number of
people.
You're not from.
I just like the Pantry for that.
If then you a small token to clarify.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
I want to make a comment about that
because one of the things that's happened
very frequently
over the last 18 months or so has been,
I've had letters
members come up to me during my talks
and said that they'd be suffering from
post traumatic stress disorder and
listening to my lectures on health and you
know,
what's the right thing here?
Because supposed to be
an express disorders.
That's
horrible condition and you know,
it's so interesting because I treated
a number of people stress disorder who
aren't military people
can find where it doesn't.
It doesn't really matter in some
sense of what I had gathered from now.
This is,
but from reading you on as
well was that people need to,
if something terrible has happened to you,
it's more than just trap.
That's on Fab,
not crunching travel fees,
backtrack traffic weeks when
your mother dies of cancer.
That's a terrible thing.
Malevolence is when someone destroys
your life on purpose or destroy someone
else's life.
That brings pain movies necessarily with
all sorts of circumstances where the
spring forward not really hurts people
and if you have post traumatic stress
disorder,
as far as I can tell,
the only thing that can bring you back,
it's to develop a religious level
philosophy of avid between good and evil.
I've seen anything I've ever seen because
first of all if you listen to someone
who have post traumatic stress disorder,
I gotta I declined.
I talk about her a little bit in this
book though I tried to disguise your
identity who was frightened into
three years of four hour long Gayley
concussions by will
invoke on her boyfriends.
That actually happened now.
She was a very naive person who thanks
to the parents and she saw a look that
man,
I am going to do everything
I possibly can to her.
And she didn't believe that such a low
awesome being very naive and that was
enough to,
well,
when she first came to be the
last diagnosis she had with,
that's what all about you fragment and
we worked through that in about a year,
about a year and she was a lot
less naive by the end of that year.
I'm telling you,
but,
but that was,
that's been so striking to me because
you know,
when you're treating someone with a
very serious psychiatric condition,
they'd be exposed to
something brutally terrible.
That there's a philosophical cure for
that or get a theological pure in some
sense of whatever.
It's really remarkable.
That can be the case.
But just for people to know that that
evil does exist in the world is a great
relief in front of buy it and
have no language to describe it.
Yeah,
I believe people exist exists
and you this and you real.
It's really real.
It's more real than anything else.
Almost except maybe then good.
And it's a relief to people to know that,
to know that that's actually the case
because then it takes them out with their
terrible isolation.
What's the vacuum and the
common realm of humanity,
you know?
And also to say,
well Tony does evil exist but it
exists in you and in each of us.
And the mere fact that it manifested
itself does not necessarily mean that
you're damned for all time,
which is really how you feel if
you have post traumatic stress.
So that's been extremely
interested in him and also great.
It's wonderful thing to have people
being hurt so badly and we can't find any
respite.
How would you say?
Well I listen to lectures
about versus tragic,
which are key lecture problem that
it's to help put you back together.
So that's good news man.
Thank you very much.
All right,
thank you for joining us again in May
cover and I just want to thank you.
I'll get to my question.
You had an interview recently with a
place to place news and there was like
[inaudible] [inaudible] the sort of
reaction that people haven't seen this,
but the reaction to the people who did
get or sort of some combination of anger
and confusion at that little
excerpt that they were meeting.
Um,
and you were talking about what sort of
rules like Hubbard men and women working
together in the workplace and
the number of related division.
Cause I wanted to ask
you about that interview,
uh,
what happened in that interview,
in what happened in that exchange
and maybe give some context to,
you know,
what was going on in that
particular exchange that,
well,
I think what happened in the interview
is what's happening as the traditional
media folds,
boobies and parish,
which is happening to the
extraordinary community newspapers.
And you go on cabinet
government for their subsequent,
you know,
that CDC and 145,000 youtube subscribers.
I don't remember what their budget is,
but it's,
it's in there,
if I remember correctly,
it's $1 billion,
but that might be wrong,
but it doesn't matter.
It's a lot.
And all the finish degenerate on
youtube does under 45,000 subscribers.
It's like,
which is absolute abject
100% catastrophic failures.
I think that there's a
bunch of reasons for that.
I mean one of them is that there is a
technological transformation of current,
right?
Because one of the things about youtube
offers everything that TV offers and a
bunch of things it doesn't offer,
so it's going to win.
It's clearly winning already and so,
and then I think that what's happening
as the classic broadcast media starts to
spiral has been good.
People start to leave.
It's a premium distribution issue.
They're good people start to leave because
they can and then those that remain
are less competent and they get more
desperate and they broadcast more and more
opinionated and Polaroids pieces to
attract the remaining audience as they
spiral towards zero
is how companies like I know how it works.
That's how it works.
And so I think the vice interview
as part of that and the injured,
there's,
there's other things that
are feeding into that.
But I think,
and maybe this is also a
consequence of the broadcast medium,
is that because broadcast
television had a very narrow time,
heavy crown contracts,
things in the small periods of time too.
It was very pronounced
tendency for journalists to
do all the interpretation and
then that turned into a pronounced
tendency for journalists to describe what
they thought and what the news was.
Right,
so that they were now
the the news rubbers,
I started noticing this
about 25 years ago with,
you know,
the news would show a politician talking,
but the newscaster would be
saying what the person said.
It's like,
well,
why have the volume missionary
at all humans have the newscast?
And that's when I stopped
watching television news and
that was reading about 25
years ago.
The vice interview was,
was that sort of taken to its extreme?
It's like he had enough,
he had an idea of what the
situation was and he was doing,
he wasn't as aggressive
about it as Kathy Newman.
It was the same sort of thing.
It's like he was not cashed me out one
way or another and not have it for about
two hours.
And he had kind of a
supercilious attitude,
um,
which is not uncommon among let's say
New York journalists and you don't,
and we talked for about two hours and
I said something that was provocative.
I would say that I said,
well,
we don't know what the rules
governing men and women's behavior,
sexual behavior in the
workplace should be.
I said,
well,
let's take makeup high heels for examples.
Like maybe they shouldn't be allowed.
I didn't say they shouldn't be allowed.
I said,
maybe they shouldn't be allowed.
That was actually what you do when
you try to think about something.
[inaudible]
my clinical practice.
So let's say I'm dealing
with someone and I say,
well,
let's think of some options for
your future and for their reading.
Nervous like right away it's like,
no,
I don't want to do that.
It's like,
well relax.
We can talk about a bunch of things.
And that doesn't mean they
have to have these life is like
for people to make out
when you get all nervous.
And he said,
well I'd want to talk about with that.
We're not really make a rule.
We're going to talk
about 10 things to make.
It might happen and none
of them are going to help.
People can finally have a bit of courage.
And maybe what we'll do when you think
is you throw out an idea and you think
about going to talk.
Well you know it's been common practice.
Men wear uniforms at work,
wear suits,
the suits a derivation
of a military uniform.
Why did men wear suits?
So they're all the same.
Why should they all be all the same?
So that unnecessary individual
variability doesn't interfere with the
functionality of the business.
Now you can argue about that.
You might say,
well he didn't want to make everyone
wear the same damn soon cause you get
involved with creativity and fair enough,
that's a reasonable argument.
But that's why the uniform,
the suit evolve.
And so if you wear a suit and I wear a
suit and go to a business meeting and the
first thing we can figure out as well,
you're at least playing the same game.
I am enough.
So that you're wearing a suit and
it's like that's not everything,
but it's not nothing.
Right.
And so well,
and then when the mine was,
you know,
with the mouth made
their advances in China,
men and women wore the same uniform.
Why?
Oh,
it was for the same reason.
That was to eliminate unnecessary
individual variability.
Well,
if you don't want sexual behavior at work,
first of all,
you've got to decide that.
Do you not want sexual behavior at work?
Cause the answer to that might not be,
we don't want sexual behavior at work.
Do you want to live?
If you want to work in an environment
where romantic entanglements are
essentially illegal,
that's what NBC has done,
right?
That's their new policy is like if there,
if you work at NBC and you know,
have coworkers who are having a romantic
engagement with another coworker,
you're obligated to report them to HR.
It's like,
well you might say no affairs at work.
Like okay,
you want to put an informer
culture in place to impose that,
do you?
Well,
maybe you do,
but maybe you should think about it
because the cure might be worse than the
disease.
It's like,
well,
like the evolutionary psychology
and biology of makeup at ideal,
if it's crystal clear,
you people dispute it that it's like,
well read the God damn literature more
on [inaudible] get so sick of this.
It's like these aren't opinions
that I'm just trying out.
You know,
why don't women were rude.
It's to make the cheeks look like fruit.
That's why were derived from fruit,
fruit,
eating primates.
We have color vision.
It's tricor man.
We pick out fruits,
right?
It's of the lipstick does.
It also indicates a sexual flush.
If you don't like that,
well tough luck for you.
That's what it is.
[inaudible]
and again,
in case you and the
swell and youthful glow,
but that's also associated
with sexual attraction.
Just cause that was one of the prime
determinants of sexual attractiveness for
women among men.
So now I'm not saying that
that shouldn't happen at work.
And then high heels.
Okay.
Why do you wear high heels?
Well,
it's because it's accepted.
It tilts your hips so that your
[inaudible] is that acceptable at work?
It's like,
no,
not of course,
no one,
of course perhaps,
but we can't have a serious discussion
on what's acceptable work and what isn't
because we're to Gambia
mature to have the discussion.
You get to the throw things
over the table like that.
It's like I don't know what the
rules should be at my workplace,
at the university,
I have been worn in numerable times not
to have a discussion with the student,
male or female,
but it's the females that
are off concerning this
particular room with the door
shut and that's it.
That's not like six months ago.
That's not like a free,
that's like advice from the last 50 years.
I don't listen to that because I think,
sorry,
I'm not living that way,
but these things are tense.
They're tense and we won't talk
about them intelligently and mature.
You know?
I've also been accused three times
in my career of sexual impropriety,
baseless accusations,
and the last one really
tangled me up for a whole year.
It's not entertaining,
so there's plenty to be sorted out.
But like I said already,
we live in the delusion of a
13 year old adolescent girl.
Maintain that level of sophistication.
We're not to have a real conversation
about what rules should govern men and
women in the workplace.
So you can't even open the damn
discussion of the jumped on like,
you know,
a ray of like rather than
heartbeat [inaudible] boots.
Like it's no bloody wonder the media is
dying if you're doing everything they
possibly can to cut their throats and
bleed out as fast [inaudible] performance
on device devices.
Some of them are irritated at me about
the makeup and ideal thing is I knew
perfectly well when I said that.
I thought,
Oh yeah,
I'll say this and it's the
only Goddamn [inaudible].
Um,
but most of the comments that
I've written so far have been,
look,
vice guys,
we know what you're up to
him pretty much sick of it.
And I know that people like Ben Shapiro's,
he won't repair it now
cause it doesn't lie.
And that's how it pretty
damn reason next day.
I was sure.
One of the things that really shocked
me about channel four in Britain.
That was the Catholic Newman thing.
So I walked into that after I had a busy
morning doing some other things at the
studio there.
I want to get to that.
And we met Kathy in the green room and
she was getting all steamed and crimped
up and [inaudible] well,
it's funny when you're on those,
those new shows,
because there's always a cloud with
people around the hosts and fixing up the
name nup it's like they're
surrounded by bees,
so it's quite comical for wash.
And so anyways,
we went out in front of
the cameras were happening,
perfectly friendly and discussion.
Um,
she was all chipper and extroverted
and having to find time.
Then he sat down and we chatted for two
minutes and then the cameras went from,
it was like different person.
Oh,
I see.
I see what's going on here.
So,
but it's this,
it's this,
it's a different mode of communication.
I think noogler gravitating towards
youtube because it's rough and ready.
It's like,
this is why Joe Rogan works.
It's like chosen are all made up.
These [inaudible] rear ended,
the smashed up truck [inaudible]
there's no printing the landscape up.
It's like here's the devotees
discussion in this three hours of it.
If you want to listen
less than if you don't,
then go hell [inaudible] states.
And it's also something that that's so
cool about youtube too is you hear this
idea that young people
have short attention spans.
It's like,
yeah,
except when it comes to [inaudible].
So it's very cool to see the shift.
But a lot of it is that
it's a death spiral.
And I think a lot of the polarization
in our society is actually a secondary
consequence.
Consequences.
It's like because the journalists are
more than one yesterday and so they're
just generating clickbait and that's
polarizing and hopefully that will stop
when the doc [inaudible] of junk.
I don't want to see the high
quality journalists was just fear.
But I don't think the high
quality journalists will
dissipated because I think
their message can move across mediums.
But I mean,
when I see CDC,
I got to watch CNBC struggle on youtube.
It's so comical.
It's like,
so I saw somebody with
CPC put it on Youtube,
it was 10 minutes long
and I want it to watch it.
And so I sat down to watch it
for three 32nd acts and I taught
for 10 minutes and you're damn content,
you really think I should pay a minute
and a half of my time to watch 10 minutes
of your condoms.
Then I couldn't click through the outs.
It's like,
so rule number one,
one app,
15 seconds long,
you can click through it for SAP.
That's the rule.
Not Three 32nd ads that
you have to sit through.
It's like have a little
respect for the media.
It's like no,
no respect.
Then upon comments were um,
no one lot,
just a lot to do that because your viewers
actually get to the comments and if
you can't hire someone to vet them,
you can just leaving the
down and comments alone.
That would be one thing.
Just let them happen.
You know,
maybe you need someone to weed out the
ones that are like so wretched that you
know,
we need to tell that you know what's up.
What would you call some demented troll,
you know,
but maybe you can just leave them alone.
They won't pay any attention to the media.
And so I look at that.
I think it's no bunny wonder,
you guys can't get any traction.
You've got no respect for
the medium whatsoever.
You're not going to make the transition.
So I'm irritated that CDC and
that's kind of good reason to,
and that sort of like,
it's coming towards the media in general,
but they're in serious trouble.
So,
so vice was a perfect example of that.
It's like you talk for two hours.
When they do,
they take the most contentious part of
it just to show how damn smart they are.
And you'll pick the people who
are watching it to see through it,
which they could.
It's like to hell with you guys.
It's like,
that's so cheap and wretched.
It's pathetic.
It's absolutely pathetic.
All you're doing is making things worse.
In in Lindsay shepherd situations,
she was recording her own side just as
insurance fraud and dishonesty from the
other side.
Yeah.
Well,
that's another thing that I've often
thought about it is just to record the
whole interview,
but I'm more or less willing at the
moment to let the chips fall where they
will.
And most of the time,
you know,
most of the time there are many
people with whom I've sat down and had
discussions where things
were played straight.
And I would say it's
actually the majority,
but there's a pretty pernicious
minority that does what?
Vice,
it's like
there's no excuse for them.
There's no excuse for it.
It's like,
you've got no principles.
Let's make this salacious.
It's like,
these things are important.
You Morons.
It's like,
get it together.
Don't muck about hell.
You
think you're doing well.
It's like up yours [inaudible]
you can't do it over to content.
So you'll do it on
manipulation that's there.
The whole g for your life.
I didn't have to do it on content,
so I'll do it on manipulation.
The model of Vice [inaudible]
[inaudible].